and they say if a person if he robs and
his hands are chopped off what about his
family what about his children Etc it's
a ruthless law I say Islam takes care of
that person has problem the Islamic
state looks after the Affairs of the
family but the question is how many
people's hands are being chopped off the
law is strict that no one dares to rob
it is so strict so where is the question
of implementing the punishment the crime
doesn't take place so where is the
question of implementing the
punishment today America which happens
to be one of the most advanced country
in the world do you know it also has one
of the highest rate of crime theft
robbery I'm asking a question if you
implement the Islamic Sharia in States
every rich person gives zakat and after
that if any man or woman robs chop off
his or her hand as a punishment I'm
asking a question will the rate of
robbery crime theft in America will it
increase will it remain the same or will
it decrease
what will
happen will it increase will it remain
the same or will it decrease it will
decrease it's a practical law you
implement the Sharia and you get results
that's the reason I say that Islam
besides speaking good things it shows
you a way how to achieve the state of
goodness and this is the reason why many
westerners today are coming to
Islam let me give you another
example that most of the philosophies
most of the religions including the
Western world says in the constitution
of the countries that you should not
molest a woman you should not rape her
if you seen the constitution of America
and European countries it's there you
should not molest a woman you should not
rape her Islam says the same but Islam
shows your a way how to achieve that
state in which people will not molest a
woman or rape a woman Islam has a system
of
hijab normally the Islamic speakers they
always speak about hijab for the women
but Allah subh
in the Glorious Quran first speaks about
the hijab for the man and then for the
woman the Quran says in chapter number
24 vers number 30 that say to the
believing man that he should lower his
gaze and guard his modesty whenever a
man looks at a woman and any Brazen
thought comes in his mind any unashamed
thought comes in his mind the Quran says
he should lower his
gaze there was once my friend who was a
Muslim who was
staring at a girl for a long time so I
told him brother what are you doing it's
not allowed in Islam so he told me our
beloved Prophet said the first glance is
allowed the second is prohibited I have
not yet completed half my
glance what did the prophet mean by
saying the first dance is allowed the
second is prohibited that doesn't mean
you can look at a woman and for 10
minutes you can look at her without
blinking and stare at her without
blinking for 10 minutes what the prophet
meant that if you look at a woman
unintentionally don't intentionally look
at her again stare at her
again the next ver speaks about the
hijab for the woman the Quran says in
Sur chapter number 24 vers number 31
that say to the believing woman that she
should lower her gaze and guard her
modesty and display not her beauty
except what appears ordinar of and draw
her whale over the bosoms and display
not the beauty except in front of her
husband her father her sons and a big
list of meam the close relatives who she
can't marry is given and the criteria
for hijab are given in the Quran and the
they're basically six
criterias for the man the extent is from
the nav to the knee for the woman the
complete body should be covered the only
parts that can be seen are the face and
the hands up to the wrist some Scholars
say that even this should be
covered the remaining five criteria are
the same for the man and the woman the
second is the clothes they wear it
should not be so tight that it reveals
the figure the third it should not be
transparent so that you can see through
fourth it should not be glamorous so
that it attracts the opposite sex fifth
it should not resemble that of the
unbeliever you cannot wear a sign of
Christianity like a cross you cannot
wear a om or Tika which is a sign of
Hinduism don't wear clothes which are
identity of an unbeliever and the last
is do not wear clothes that which
resemble the opposite sex in the Western
World we have men wearing one
earring it has certain sign significance
one
yearing such things are prohibit in
Islam
and hijab is not confined only to the
clothing it also includes the moral
conduct the behavior the attitude the
intention of a person besides hijab of
the clothes there should be hijab of the
eyes hijab of the Mind hijab of the
thought hijab of the
heart a person
should even have hijab in the way he
talks the way he
behaves the way he
thinks and the reason for hijab for the
woman is mentioned in the Glorious Quran
in Surah aab 33:59 which says that oh
Prophet tell your wives and the
believing women that when they go abroad
they should put on the cloak so that
they shall be
recognized the Quran gives the reason
put on the cloak so that they shall be
recognized and they shall not be
molested the Quran says hijab has been
prescribed to prevent the woman from
being
molested for example if there are two
sisters who are twins and very beautiful
they walking down the streets of K
kampur and one twin
sister she's wearing the Islamic hijab
that is complete body covered except the
face and the hands up to the wrist and
the other twin sister was equally
beautiful very beautiful she's wearing
the western clothes the skirt or the
mini and they're walking down the street
and around the corner there's a holigan
there's a rafian who's waiting for a
catch who's wearing to tease a girl I'm
asking a question which girl will he
tease will it tease the girl wearing the
Islamic hijab or will it tease the
sister who's wearing the skirt of the
mini which girl will he tease but
natural he will tease the girl wearing
the skirt of the mini she's
inviting the people who tease her the
Quran rightly says that hijab prevents
the woman from being molested
and after this the Glorious Quran says
that if any man rapes a woman capital
punishment death
penalty the westerners may say death
penalty in this age of Science and
Technology in the 20th century Islam is
a barbaric religion people
may but when I ask this question to the
westerners I've gone this several times
that suppose someone God forbid it rapes
wife or rapes your mother and if suppose
you meet the judge and the rapist is
bought in front of
you what punishment will you give him
and believe me all of them said we will
put the rapist to death some went to the
extreme of saying we will torture him to
death so I tell the westerners why the
double standards somebody rap somebody
else's wife you say oh death penalty is
a barbaric law somebody rapes your wife
and your mother you say you want to put
him to death why they double standards
only one person one Westerner so far has
given me a different answer you know he
told me that
first I will give the rapist if someone
raped my wife I will first give him
seven years
imprisonment and next time if he rapes
my wife again or he rapes anyone then I
will give death penalty there are some
smart Alex you know who give new anwers
there are smart
Al so I told the brother do you know the
statistics of America they tell us that
when a man is convicted for rape the
American government says 7 years
rigorous
imprisonment but the statistics tell us
that those people who have even
convicted and undergo the punishment
after they let free 95% of them again
commit
rap so I told that Wester that American
if you like your wife to be raped again
you are most welcome to give seven years
and then put him to death I wouldn't
like that I put him to death on the
first time irres whether he raped my
wife or your wife if you like your
mothers to be raped again and again you
can try that law and then he got the
shock of his life and I told the
statistics he said if that the case then
even I would put him to that the first
time Islam has the
solution we know today in America
according to statistics according to the
FBI statistics of 1990 it said that
throughout the year in the year 1990 10
12,555 cases of rape were
reported and it said that out of the
cases that were
reported only 16% of the total cases
were reported if you want to know the
total number of rape that took place
multiply the figure by 6.25 and you get
the answer of
64,9 168 cases of rape took place alone
in the year 199
if you divide this figure by 365 the
number of days every day on average in
the year 1990
1,756 rapes took place I read another
Statistics later on which said that
every day more than 1,900 cases of rape
take place in USA alone the year was not
given maybe it was 92 93 the Americans
got more bold you know
1,900 that means every 1.3 minute 1 of
rap taking place you know I'm here since
more than last time already more than 40
rapes might taken place in USA I'm here
for one and 40 rapes may have taken
place in
USA and the statistics of FBI 1990
Contin then says that out of those cases
that were reported 16% out of those
reported 10% were arrested that mean
1.6% of the rapist they were arrested
out of those arrested 50% were let free
before the trial that means only 8% of
the rapist they under a trial that means
if a man commits 125 rapes the chances
that he'll undergo a trial and get a
punishment is only one 125 rapes you
commit and you get a punishment once
it's a very good gamble 125 rapes you
commit and chances the government will
give you a punishment is one it's a very
good
Gamble and out of those that undergo a
trial 50 50% get a punishment of less
than one year though the American law
say 7 years rigorous imprisonment but
the judge said first time he's committed
rape now give him benefit of Doubt let
it the lenient 125 rapes he commits she
come to the trial once and the judge
says let's be lead it first time he's
committed these are the statistics of
FBI of
USA I'm asking a question if you
implement the Islamic Sharia in USA that
every man he looks at woman he should
lower his case when any Breen thought
comes in his mind the woman should be
Islamic hijab complete body covered
except the face and hands up the wrist
and after this if any man commits rape
capital punishment death penalty I
asking a question will the rate of rape
in America will it increase will it
remain the same or will it
decrease it will decrease it's a
practical law you implement the Sharia
and you get
results and Islam alhamdulillah as I
said has the solution to the problem of
mankind and one of the major problems in
the western world is
alcoholism which leads to other problems
also
and the Glorious Quran has the solution
it says in Sur ma chapter number 5 verse
number
90 oh you who
believe most certainly intoxicant and
gambling dedication of stones divination
of arrows
these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handiwork
that you may Prosper the Quran says that
alcoholism gambling these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handiwork
that you may
Prosper you know there is an inhibit
Center in the brain you know which
prevents you from doing things which are
not correct for example if I have to go
for Call of nature my inhib don't do it
here go to the
toilet if I'm speaking to Elders my
inity Center will say speak with respect
don't abuse your parents don't abuse
your elders inhibitory Center is working
now when you're intoxicated this
inhibitory Center is
inhibited by the alcohol no wonder you
find many alcoholics they unate in the
cloth itself they speak with abusive
language they don't respect the parent
when they're intoxicated and they don't
care who is in front of them they keep
on speaking anything the inhibitory
Center is
inhibit
and the
statistics of the Western World tells us
especially of the states
that majority of the rapes that take
place majority means more than 95% of
the rape that take place it is in the
state of
intoxicants either the rapist is
intoxicated or the victim who was raped
is
intoxicate more than 95% and almost all
of the cases of incest you know incest
incest means sex with close
relatives father and daughter mother and
son brother and sister
incest it's in the case when the people
are
intoxicated
majority of rape more than 95% almost
all of the incest is in the state of in
seconds
and imagine even the AIDS one of the
reasons for AIDS to spread is
alcoholism which is very dangerous
disease one of the reasons is alcoholism
there are people who say oh you know we
are only social drinkers we only have
social Drinker just once in a while you
know some people say in cold country
because if we cold we have only one p of
beer it's not harmful so I tell them
that if you're feeling cold why don't
you sit next to the
fireplace no we want to drink something
you know I said if you want to drink
something why don't you have honey honey
keeps you more warm than alcohol but in
the honey there's no kick which you get
in the
beer people have
excuses and there are some westerners
you know who told me let's see brother
Zak
Islam I don't mind accepting but the
thing is that I cannot give up my
alcohol
there are certain people who only one
excuse for not accepting Islam so I told
that brother let suppose suppose I give
you a fatwa suppose that for you alcohol
is Forgiven if you have alcohol it's
forgiven just for sake of argument will
you accept Islam
then he was silent people want to give
excuse for not accepting it not that
that was the only reason why he's not
accepting
Islam saying that no Islam is a good
relig but I cannot give up my alcohol so
I said okay fine at Le give up your sh I
will tell you that even if alcohol no
problem Allah May forgive you sh Allah
will never forgive you if you do shik
Allah will never forgive you no problem
if that's your only hitch from accepting
Islam I will give you a certificate that
no problem you have alcohol other things
that you follow of Islam this is trying
to use hikma as I said there an excuse
if people don't accept Islam but then
Islam has a solution to the problems
there are people who say my father he
he's a social Drinker since a long time
so I tell the people every drunkard when
you interview him every alcoholic you
interview him and you can ask the
doctors when you interview them no
alcoholic starts drinking because he
wants to become
alcoholic no alcoholic starts drinking
because he wants to become a
drunker he starts as a social Drinker
and many of them end up becoming
drunkards and then some people say you
know my father he is a social Drinker
and he very he has good willpower he has
only one peg a week and one peg twice a
week and he never gets intoxicated so I
tell that any human being who's been
having alcohol since several years you
ask him that has he ever been
intoxicated in his life and no one can
say no if he's been a social Drinker
also at least a few times in his life he
has to be intoxicated and if suppose
during that time if he commits a crime
like rape or incest will any modest
person be ever able to forgive himself
again the loss that is done irreparable
irreversible loss done to him and the
victim is
unforgivable suppose in the state of
intoxic if you get intoxicated once and
suppose you commit rape or suppose you
commit incest your father sleep with the
daughter will he ever be able to forgive
himself therefore our beloved Prophet
said mallam it's mentioned
ma volume number three in the book of
intoxicants chapter number 30 Hadith
number 3392 that anything which
intoxicates you in large quantity is
even prohibited in small quantity no
excuse
for our beloved Prophet said it's
mentioned ma volume number three in the
book of intoxicant chapter number 30
Hadith number 3371 that intoxicants are
the mother of all evil is it is a mother
of all evils because of intoxic have so
much of evil in
society molestation rape disease Etc
s and the prophet said that 10
categories of people are cursed those
who are involved with alcohol it's
mentioned ma volume number three in the
book of intoxicant chapter number 30
Hadith number 3380 and the prophet said
anyone who's involved in 10 categories
with alcohol
Allah's curse is on such people those
that distill
alcohol those who distill it for others
those who drink it those who transport
it those who transport it for somebody
else those who serve it those who sell
it those who utilize the profits of the
sales those who bite and those who bite
for someone else all these 10 types of
people Allah's curse is on these
people and there are several diseases
which a person can have by having
intoxicant you can give a talk only only
on the ill effects of alcohol which the
Western world knows about it not that
they don't know therefore they have
several resolutions passed which I shall
discuss one later on and you can give a
talk only listing the names of diseases
will take you full day I'll just mention
a few one of the most dangerous disease
which associated with the personing
alcohol is therosis of
liver having intoxicants a person can
also have carcinoma of the esophagus
carcinoma of the head and neck carcinoma
of the stomach carcinoma of the liver a
person can have esophagitis gastritis
pancreatitis hepatitis he can have
cardiomyopathy he can have angina he can
have hypertension he can have
arthrosclerosis all these associated
with having alcohol a person can have
periph
neuropathy cortical atrophy cereal
atrophy if he has alcohol a person can
be associated with Strokes with fits
with paralysis with apoplexy a person
can have one Cal syndrome which is a
syndrome associated with loss of
immediate memory and confabulation and
retention of past memory due to thond
deficiency which is associated with
intake of alcohol a person can also have
disease like paga berry berry he can
have delirium tmin it takes place a lot
of time postoperatively and infection
and especially a person who abstained
from intoxicant and if a person is
suffering from this even in advanced
hospitals sometimes he can die he can
have several endocrinal disorders such
as mixa
hypothyroidism crushing syndrome he can
have hematological disorders like Zen
syndrome he can have folic acid
deficiency in which there is microcytic
anemia he can have platel disorders
thrombocytopenia common drugs which a
person takes like flag that meton all
can come in between if he regularly
takes
alcohol if a person takes alcohol
regularly his power to fight the
diseases his immunity goes down there
are chances of infection of the
respiratory tract they can be disas of
the lung like empyema like pulmonary
tuberculosis like lung absis and when a
person vomits his scough reflex is
reduced during intoxicant and the
vomitus can go into the lung causing
lung absis as well as emphysema a person
can even die due to this problem and
this problem of intoxicant of alcohol is
further multiplied in the woman a woman
has more chances of loss of liver as
compared to the man and if a woman is
pregnant and if she takes alcohol there
are chances of having alcohol feetal
syndrome it even affects the baby there
are several disease there can be skin
disease like alopatia eczema
parona stomatitis several disease you
can only list the diseases for days
together and discuss from months
together but today's
doctors the
westerners they tell us in the medical
journalist that alcoholism is a
disease it's a disease it's not
addiction you know like how you have
typhoid you have perate tuberclosis and
normally people are sympathetic towards
people who have disease if a person is
sick you're sympathetic poor person he
has got typhoid he has got influenza
he's suffering from inless so today's
doctors tell us that alcoholism is a
disease so I tell them if alcoholism is
a disease it is the only disease that is
sold in
bottles it's the only disease that has a
licensed outlet for its sale it's the
only disease that brings the revenue to
several governments of the world
including the Western Government it's
the only disease that is advertised in
the television on the satellite on the
radio in the newspapers in the magazines
it is the only disease which brings
violent deaths on the highways it's the
only disease that destroys families it's
the only disease which has got no viral
or germ cause it's not a disease the
Quran says in 5 vers number
19 it's not a disease it's a Satan's
handiwork abstain from this handiwork
that you may
prosper and Islam also has a solution
there are chances that you may get
allured by by these problems which the
West has which the world has so Islam
has a solution how to stay away from
this problem that is
Salah Salah doesn't only mean prayer to
pray means to ask for
help to Beech in Salah besides asking
for help we also seek Allah subh T's
guidance and we also praise him
therefore I prefer calling Salah as a
sort of programming sort of conditioning
because in the Salah we are conditioned
we are programmed but if someone says
where are you going and if you say I'm
going for programming or brainwashing it
will sound odd therefore people say
prayer for Salah I've got no obic but
that doesn't denote the complete meaning
of Salah because in Salah we are being
reminded when the IM recites certain
verses after Sur fat he may recite Surah
Bak 2 vers 188 that do not use your
wealth as bit for judges that means do
not bribe he may recite Sur ma 5:
number9 that against and gambling the
Satan's handiwork we are being
programmed again and again because the
world allows you so much there are
chances that we can get deprogrammed
therefore Allah subhana tala has shown
us a solution that how to keep us
reprogrammed a sort of
conditioning
today the Western World they afraid of
only one
thing the maximum that the Western world
today is afraid of is of
Islam by Western world I mean the
leaders of the Western World they afraid
of
Islam they
afraid you know
why
because the amount of enjoyment that
they're taking is because of all the
evil that there in Society Western world
is afraid that if all these evils stop
if Islam becomes prevalent all this evil
will stop alcohol will stop dancing will
stop and quoting will stop raping will
stop and who will fill the cfers so the
leaders of the western world most of
them they afraid of Islam that's the
reason the media regularly is pumping
information against Islam on the
television if you hear on the radio in
the magazines in the newspaper all the
information is against Islam is
maligning Islam if you hear any bom BL
that takes place it has to be a Muslim
the Muslim they fundamentalist and
terrorists
even the oklah bombing the headlines was
Middle East conspiracy after some time
when they come to know it was an
American Soldier but that comes inside
in the P doesn't come on the headlines
Muslims are fundamentalist comes on the
headlines and the real reason comes
inside and you have certain times even
in some countries that a 50y old
Muslim he has married a 16year old girl
small letters with permission that's
there but 50 50y old Muslim marries a
16-year-old girl headlines on the front
page it will
come but when a non-muslim 50-year-old
man rapes a six-year-old girl it may
come in news brief news
brief somewhere in the corner 50-year
old man it's so
common so with permission if you marry
with the permission of the girl of the
parents it doesn't go down the throat so
therefore the leaders of the Western
World they are maligning Islam
Muslims are fundamentalist Muslim are
terrorists Islam subjugates the women
and all these the answers of all these
are given in my cassette M rights to
Islam it's even given misconception
about Islam you can refer to
that but in spite of this though the
Western leaders are against Islam
alhamdulillah many westerners are coming
to
Islam the right word would not be
the question POS is why is the West
coming to Islam and the actual answer is
the West is not coming to Islam the West
is returning to
Islam because our beloved Prophet said
that every man is born in that means
innate religion he's born as a Muslim
later on due to the influence of Elders
and parents and other people the child
starts doing idol worship or fire
worship so the right word is people say
convert I normally say revert convert
means a person from one TR goes to the
other revert means a person on the right
track he goes to the wrong track and
comes back to the right track so the
more correct and appropriate word is
revert therefore I would say the West is
not coming the West is returning to
Islam because Islam has the solution to
the problems of mankind and not only the
West Islam is not only meant for the
West Islam is meant for the whole of
humankind the Glorious Quran was not
revealed only for the Muslim or the
Arabs or only for the Western world it's
mentioned in the Quran in Surah ibraim
14 verse number one
Al these are the ayats of the book which
we have revealed to the of prophet
Muhammad Salli wasallam so that you may
lead the humankind from Darkness to
light not only lead the Muslims or the
Arabs of the Western World lead the
whole of humankind from Darkness to
light Quran says in Sur Bak 2 185 that
Ramadan was the month in which the Quran
was revealed as a criteria to judge
right from wrong as a guide to the whole
of humankind Quran says in Surah Alum 39
verse number 41 that we have revealed to
the prophet Muhammad sallahu Ali
wasallam the book to instruct humankind
not only to instruct the Arabs or the
Muslims or the westerners to instruct
the whole of humankind and Prophet
Muhammad s wasallam was not sent as a
messenger to the Muslims or the Arabs
alone or to the Western world alone
Quran says in Surah 21 verse number
107 that we have sent thee not but as a
mercy to all the worlds as a mercy to
all the creatures as a mercy to the
whole of humankind Quran says in Surah
Sabah 34 verse
28 that we have sent the not but as a
universal
messenger giving them bad Tidings and
warning them against sin but most of the
human beings yet do not know so Islam is
not a religion only for the West it's a
religion for the whole of humankind no
wonder if you read the articles of plain
truth which was a reproduction of
article that came in the reader R Al
manic year book 1986 it gave the
statistics of the increase of the
percentage of major world religions from
the year 1934 to 1984 in the span of 50
years it gave the increase of the
percentage of major world religion
number one was Islam
235% Christianity only
47% today the fastest growing religion
in America is Islam the fastest going
religion in Europe is Islam and that's
the prophecy which has come true as
Allah says in the Glorious Quran in
Surah saf 61 vers number 9 as well as
number 9 verse number 33
that Allah has sent his messenger with
wisdom and the religion of Truth so that
it will prevail over all the other
religions over all the other isms over
all the other ways of life whether it be
atheism secularism Marxism communism
westernism Islam is destined to
supersede all master them all overcome
them
all however much the mush don't like it
how much the idol worshippers don't like
it and the same message repeat for the
third time with a different ending in
Surah fat chapter 48 verse number 28
that Allah has sent his messenger with
wisdom and religion of Truth so that it
will prevail over all the other isms
over all the other ways of life whether
it be Hinduism Judaism christianism
communism secularism atheism westernism
Islam is dist to supersede all master
them all overcome them
all and enough is Allah as a witness
Allah is giving shahada that this
religion of Islam will prevail
throughout the world I would like to end
my talk by giving the translation of The
Words which I started my talk with from
Al Imran 3 verse number 19 which
says ISL the only religion acceptable in
the site of Allah is Islam
thank you Dr Zakir I'm sure you'll agree
with me that you have in front of you a
very exceptional
person okay some rules about the the the
questions try to be precise uh to the
point try not to be give a commentary uh
or a
lecture um and if you have more than one
questions please ask one first and then
give others a chance and then wait for
your turn again I hope we'll be we'll be
fair and cooperative and um so that I
don't have to interfere much um
please if you want to have written
questions you can pass to the
[Music]
front my question is on
polygamy um according to the Quran it is
very clear that polygamy is allowed yet
there's very there are very serious
rules involved there's serious Justice
involved so when man commits I me when a
man practices polygamy he's actually
putting himself on trial while on the
other hand according to the statistics
you have quoted for us polygamy seems to
be the only answer out to all the
problems that the West is facing today
due to the very high number of females
involved but let's be realistic every
man who practices polygamy or marries
even more than one wife is actually
putting himself on trial your comments
please
the sister asked a very good question
and she said that a person can practice
according to the Quran polygen polygen
is more appropriate than polygamy
polygamy includes polygen and polyandry
polyandry is prohibited in the Quran for
reasons different which one I can tell
polygen is allowed and Sheely said that
if a person practices polygeny he's
putting himself to test and that's what
even we are doing sister here in the
world Allah says that we want to only be
just pass I want to undergo this test
the human beings were fools who took
this test and we undergoing the test
sister as a good question that if you
marry more than one you're undergoing a
test I do agree if you fail the test
you'll be in problem I do agree but if
you pass then you get plus points also
because polygen has been allowed in
Islam to protect the woman but natural
and the prophet did say that the person
is best who's best to his wife and if he
has more than one wife he has to do
justice which is difficult the
statistics are quoted that there are
millions of women throughout the world
but the ratio I haven't told you the
ratio is that for every
1,000 men in the world there are 1,5
women that means half perc mean out of
thousand men five if they marry more
than one half% in Short therefore Allah
hasn't made the ratio so much he hasn't
made 1 is to four the woman aren't four
times more than the men they only half%
more and many are times it's a give and
take that's a few of the reasons of
polygen I've told you there are various
other reasons you know man is polygenis
by nature and suppose he has hyposexual
Etc which is more in man as compared to
the woman then his option is instead of
going to the marketplace instead of
going and having Mistresses the other
option is having more than one wife so
for such people it's a dual thing for
himself also as well as protection for
the woman who require it so Islam
alhamdulillah is just it's not overing
anyone therefore it's not a f in Islam
to marry more than one woman but if you
marry and if you do justice then
inshallah you're on the positive point
you will get S if you marry more than
one woman and do justice but do justice
is difficult so those people who can do
and who require it alhamdulillah they
can do it Allah will bless them but
those who can't it's not a f that you
should marry neither a must but if you
do any act and do it properly Allah is
surely going to bless you hope that
answer the
question I want to ask one question as I
was listening to your talk I was know
was very nice and everything so I want
to ask you a question I say I'm a mother
who have children growing up as you have
done so well in your academics you are a
doctor and going around giving lectures
and to have children like like you more
person like you in this world what did
your parents did know to have a person
like you so you I want you to give us
some advice for mothers like me to know
more details to bring up thank
you asked a very good question that
after seeing my talks becoming a doctor
and giving such talk she ask what did my
parents do and Dr Yaya gave a very good
uction and he rightly said if I have to
thank anyone in this world after Allah
subhana wa ta'ala the first person is my
mother and but natural my father and the
other family members including my wife
alhamdulillah after I got married in
modaa it's a full family effort people
normally ask me you know and they tell
me that you know that if you have to be
very good ET you have to do Family
Planning normally people say I say I'm
the fifth child of my parents if my
parents would have done Family Planning
I wouldn't have been here so I thought
maybe that is the question she's going
to ask alhamdulillah she that I'm the
fifth child and alhamdulillah people
think that having more children is a b
but alhamdulillah it turns out to be
Boon also depending how you upbring them
and how do you
follow just Nell I would say that my
parents
alhamdulillah they they let me think
freely they didn't have any particular
blinkers that you know follow this
religiously alhamdulillah my parents are
religious alhamdulillah they didn't
force anything on me let me think freely
but they followed the guidance of the
Quran and the Sunnah alhamdulillah so
because they want the Quran Sunnah and
when a child sees that the parents are
on the right very often alhamdulillah
the children emulate the parent but
that's not always the case we have
instances of children of prophets going
astray it is but natur I said after the
help of Allah subhana wa tala it is
Allah subhana wa taala whose help is
most required parents is required and as
I said one of the reasons is as
mentioned Sur Al Imran chapter number
three verse number 160 that if Allah
helps you no one can overcome you if
Allah forsakes you then there is no one
who can overcome you then if Allah
forsakes you no one can help you so let
the Believers put their trust in Allah
subhana wa tala my parents put their
trust in Allah subhana tala you know the
amount of money they spend in making me
a doctor and my mother's desire was my
son should be the best doctor and she
was want me to become like someone like
Chris Bernard the person with the first
heart transplantation CH Bern from South
Africa and since my mother had met him
and that was a desire so alhamdulillah
even I wanted to become a doctor and I
took the medical profession because as I
thought that and it is alhamdulillah not
that I've changed my view that first I
had the impression that doctor is the
best profession to serve Humanity it is
one of the good professions so that's
why I became a doctor and my father was
a doctor psychiatrist and that's how
alhamdulillah I became a doctor but then
by being inspired by Ahmed I got
involved in dawa and then I found that I
used to find pleasure in treating the
patient physically but I got more
pleasure multiple times more in treating
the patient spiritually multiple times
more and there are thousands of doctors
in the world many hundreds of them who
are giving free treatment I would be
another Drop in the
Ocean so that's the time I decided to
give up my profession and turn as a
full-time Dy and in which my parents
they supported me but natur my parents
would have said we have spent so much
money on you we had so much High Hopes
in you Etc now you to leave the
profession five and a half years you
spend in medicine and then but
alhamdulillah my parents supported me
they said no problem it's in the way of
Allah
alhamdulillah I asked my mother what
would you like me to become and I wanted
to give up my profession would you like
me to become like Ahmed or like Chris
ban so she gave a very witing reply I
would like you to become both
together but now when I ask her that
would you want me to become a d like
what I am now or would you want me to
become like Chris ban she says that one
D likeed I can sacrifice a thousand
Chris alhamdulillah it support of the
parents which helps me because support
of the parents and family is very
important in doing dawa how to upbring
the children I've given the talk Islam
for children system Islam for children
that the best teacher for the children
is the mother and I say that the first
book that the mother or the parent
should give to the child is the
Quran Quran is the first book and it
will remain a guide for your children
till the last day of his
life and but natural our parents didn't
know that in Arabic is so important
learning Arabic as a language so I give
a talk on alquran should it be read with
understanding and showed the importance
of Arabic it's important that you should
even teach your children Arabic as a
language it will help them to understand
Islam better and but natural if anyone
strives in the way of Allah if you
strive in the way of Allah subhana wa
tala Allah says inah an kab 29: 69 if
you strive in his way he will open up
your Pathways so you strive and you see
to it that if you want what you want you
striving the right way Allah subhana wa
tala will inshallah open up your
Pathways so first is Faith in Allah
second is striving third is technique
hope the answer
question uh good evening I have a
question it's about polygamy also if
Islam uh if Islam were to have a system
like the zakat why can't they have
another system similar to zakat to
overcome the overp population a female
in the world thank
you the brother asked a question that
how dides Islam have the system of zakat
to overcome the poverty and crime why
doesn't have a similar system for po
that's what it has in zakat what do you
do you share your wealth right or wrong
in polyam what do you
do the woman shares the
husband so alhamdulillah you give a very
good striking
resemblance I never thought of Prof it
before you made me
think you know I learn from the question
answer therefore I love it the more I
answer the questions the more my answers
improve alhamdulillah and many of times
you know Allah gives the answers on the
stage alhamdulillah he gives theam and
more people ask me question the more my
mind works and alhamdulillah I can add
to my lecture next time that Zak is
somewhat like polygam you can compare
alhamdulillah it has the solution how it
for wealth you share your wealth here
some wom should share the husband and
that solves the problem so that so that
the modesty of the other women is
protected hope that answer the
question um alhamdulillah it has always
uh you have mentioned that um uh the
West is coming to Islam as promised by
Allah in the Quran and uh also the the
embracing of Islam by by uh
non-believers were because of HMA that
was given by Allah but I just want to
know in the west despite the fact that
Islam has been
um adulterated and condemned and the
behavior of some Muslims were were not
Islamic what is it that that that
intrigues the the non-muslims to learn
more about Islam is it the behavior of
some Muslims is it the contribution of
Da in the west or what exactly it is I
mean uh uh putting aside the the hi that
Allah has given this people sister
that's a very good question that in
spite the media the Western world is
against Islam how come westerners are
yet alhamdulillah accepting
Islam because but is important she
rightly said that the most important is
it because dies are going around is it
because they're looking at the Muslims
in the west and they accepting Islam or
is it something else so it's rightly
said first is
the and I wouldn't say that looking at
the Muslims all the West would accept
Islam
like brother y Islam said that it's good
that I read the Quran first before
meeting the Muslims if I had met the
Muslims I wouldn't have accepted Islam
that's his view that's his view maybe
the Muslims he met weren't that good but
there are many people in the world to
accept Islam only by looking at the
Muslim therefore what I say normally in
my talk people say Islam talk such good
things but you're Muslim some people are
cheating they are bribing they doing
wrong things so what I tell
them that there are black sheeps in
every Community there are black sheeps
in every Community you know that we have
Muslim the cheat who bribe who dealing
drugs many Muslims who I know can drink
the non-muslim under the table you know
they expert in drinking the media what
they do they pick up these black sheep
and they project as Exemplar Muslim they
pick up the black sheeps and they
portray as Exemplar Muslim as though
every Muslim is a cheat every Muslim is
a drunkard every Muslim does wrong
things it the main for fault of the
media they're doing for their own
reasons so that they fill the
cuffers so I tell them that on a whole
Muslims alhamdulillah we are the biggest
community of tea tolers who don't embe
alcohol we are the community which gives
a maximum charity no non-muslim can show
us a candle where sobriety is concerned
where modesty is
concerned where humanity is concerned
where ethics is concerned Western media
picks up Black Sheep and project them as
samples so what I give the example that
suppose if you want to judge a car
suppose a new model of Mercedes-Benz is
there in the market I don't know which
is a new model maybe e230 of 1998 or
whatever it is and you want to judge how
good the car
is you let a person drive the Mercedes
car who doesn't know how to drive and he
bangs up the car who will you blame will
you blame the car or will you blame the
driver who will you blame the driver so
if you want to judge the car don't look